MALE SPEAKER: So
now that we know
how to unlock an achievement,
let's make some progress
towards unlocking an
incremental achievement.
As you recall, one
of the achievements
we wanted to implement is
our Centaguesser achievement.
This is an achievement
that a player
earns for making 100 guesses.
And this is an
incremental achievement
meaning that we want the
player to see that they've
made a certain amount
of progress every time
they play the game.
And so let's get to
implementing that.
This process is fairly
similar to what we did before.
In my Achievement
Manager, I'm going
to create a method,
Increment Achievement with ID
and we'll have our NS
string achievement ID.
Say by amount.
Let's get that colon in there.
There we go.
And we'll have an INT that
will reflect our progress.
And now we can
implement this method.
We'll go down here
and once again,
like before, we're going to
create a GPGAchievement object.
We'll call this
one Increment Me.
And we're going to call
GPGAchievement, achievement
with ID, and pass in our
achievement ID string.
And then, Increment Me,
instead of unlock achievement
with completion handler, we will
say increment achievement NUM
steps, with a
completion handler.
Now this number of steps
is the amount of progress
that we want to make towards
unlocking this achievement.
Remember we're doing this for
our Centaguesser achievement
where we want the user to make
a 100 guesses so this will
be the number of guesses that
the user has made every game.
So it might be seven,
then maybe it'll be six,
then maybe it will
be 12, and then four.
And so our number
of steps by which
we want to increment
this achievement
is the progress variable
that we pass in.
And then we have our
completion handler.
And put this on a
new line and we're
going to have three arguments
passed into our completion
handler.
First, how we newly
unlocked this achievement,
that is have we
made enough progress
towards completing
this achievement
that we've unlocked it.
Current steps is the
number of total steps
that the player has now made
as reported by your system.
And error is if
there's any error.
Now by the way, if we wanted,
we could leave this all blank
and everything will
work just fine,
the library will
record everything,
and it will display an
achievement unlocked toast
when appropriate.
But just so we can
see what's going on,
we'll do some logging here.
So if error, we'll NSLog.
Got an error.
Our incrementing and
achievement and we'll
pass in our
localized description
and otherwise if newly
unlocked, NS log.
Hooray!
Newly unlocked.
I suppose in either case, we can
NSLog according to the system.
Your total progress is
now percent d steps.
And this will be current steps.
Close that up.
And that's about it.
We now have a generic
method to make progress
towards an achievement.
Let's go back to our
game model and we're
going to increment this
achievement from our player
guess method.
Now you might be tempted
to just increment
this achievement here.
Every time the
player makes a guess,
you would call self dot
achievement manager, increment
achievement, by
ID, whatever we're
calling it, by amount one.
However, this will
run you into trouble.
And that's because when you
call GPG increment achievement,
our games client will actually
go out onto the network
and try to make a
network call every time.
And if this were to happen very
frequently, if a player were
to make a lot of
guesses, there's
a chance that your
game could end up
getting throttled by your system
for making too many network
calls.
This is probably in contrast
to Game Center's recommendation
where I believe they
encourage you to make progress
towards achievements constantly.
I'm pretty sure this is because
Game Center's on device client
is much more aggressive about
caching and automatically
batching network calls than
our client currently is.
We're looking into
making improvements
to ours in the future,
but for right now,
our recommendation is not to
increment achievement by one
every single time.
So here's what we're
going to do instead.
Once the player has
won a game, we're
going to call self dot
achievement manager
and we're going to increment
our Centaguesser achievement
by the total number of guesses
that the player has made.
So we're only making this
achievement increment call once
per game instead
of once per guess.
And that will work
out a whole lot better
both in terms of the
system not throttling
your game and your user's
device not having to go out
onto the network
every three seconds.
We can get our achievement
ID by once again going
to the developer console
and in Guess My Number,
go to My Achievements,
and here's
my Centaguesser achievement.
Copy that.
We'll paste it in here.
Yes, it does kind of bug me
that these two strings look
nearly identical
but there you go.
So now we can run this and it
looks like our build succeeded.
And we'll go to our
application here
and check out our achievements.
Once again, my Centaguesser
achievement is still at 0%
but now I'm going to
play a game and I'm
going to make a few guesses.
Some more guesses.
This is six guesses and I think
this will be our seventh guess.
So we've hit our game over call.
Let's look at what's
happening in the log here.
So we've got two messages
here on our counsel log.
This first one,
according to the system,
your total progress
is now seven steps
is what we got back from
our increment achievement
with ID callback.
So that means that we
didn't get an error,
newly unlocked is false because
this has not been unlocked yet,
but we've now recorded our
total progress as seven steps.
And the second message
looks like you've
earned this one
already is because we
told the system to try
and unlock our first timer
achievement and that one
has already been earned.
By the way, this is completely
normal programming style.
You don't need to perform any
special logic on your side
to detect whether the user has
earned this achievement or not
yet and perform an unlock call
depending on whether they have
or whether they haven't.
From your perspective,
I would encourage
you to just not worry about it.
Feel free to submit an
achievement multiple times.
Either our client will
catch it or the server
will catch it and say,
you know, it's OK.
The user's already earned this.
And that's completely
normal behavior.
We don't expect you to
perform a lot of logic just
to keep track of this stuff.
And, by the way, if I
were to run this again,
and I were to make
a few more guesses.
You see I've made seven guesses
and in my increment achievement
with ID callback and
you've seen the call.
I'm specifying the amount
of progress is seven
but what gets returned back
by the system is now 14.
Again, I believe this is--
unlike Game Center-- where it's
your client's job to keep track
of the total amount of progress
the user has made towards
unlocking an achievement,
Play Games, all
you need to do is
record the amount of
progress the user has made
for that game and the system
will add up your achievement
progress for you.
So there we go.
We have now successfully
incremented an achievement,
as well as unlocked
an achievement.
We have two more
achievements to implement
but before we add those
in, I don't know about you,
but it's kind of
bothering me that we've
got our achievement IDs embedded
right there within the code.
So I think in our
next lesson, we're
going to clean this
up a little bit,
just get these out
of here, and then
we'll implement these
last two achievements.
So I'll see you soon.